- No!
What up Captain?
- Thanksgiving is coming up.
- Yes, Thanksgiving's coming up.
- We're gonna have the greens and the
macaroni and the dressings.
- What's your opinion on turkey?
- I'm into turkey.
- What's your opinion on turkeys?
- It's not my animal of choice
if I'm gonna have like a zoo.
- Have you ever met one?
- Ever met a turkey?
- Yeah.
- Uh, no I have not.
- Would you like to?
- No!
- Oh my God! (laughing)
- Oh, that acutally, actually no.
- I'm finna to cry, that's a real one?
- Ohhhhhh.
- Turkey gonna come out flying and crazy.
I don't wanna do this.
- Tori!
- The turkey's name is Captain Turk.
- What?
- How delightful.
- Awww, Captain Turk, hi little guy.
- Oh, didn't see you there,
do you come around here often?
- There's nothing to be
scared of, you're the
fastest turkey in the world.
- It's a boy?
- It's a handsome young boy.
- What's a turkey call?
- OOLULULU LULU.
- Tori do you wanna try that?
- oulululu.
- Oullululu.
- Oululululu.
- Like they don't say gobble gobble?
- Oh, sorry.
- Hahahaha.
- Oh yeah, now we gotta
turn towards camera.
- Oh, woah, ham is quick.
- Oh, shake it off, you got
some Taylor Swift going on.
- Oh my God, he's amazing.
- That's real.
- [Voiceover] This bird
looks like a 50 year old man.
- Would you like to take a selfie with me?
- Look at the camera turkey.
- Hi!
- Yo, Captain.
- Hahaha.
It's so good, he looks not
happy and I look super stoked.
There we go, Happy Thanksgiving!
- Looking at Captain Turk,
do you believe that this is
perhaps a more proper
symbol of our strong nation?
- No I like the eagle.
- So we're gonna keep the bald eagle?
- The bald eagle.
- And we're just gonna eat the turkey?
- Yep.
- Okay.
- Poop there, poop there
and where the turkey stepped
in it and walked, poop
a little bit everywhere.
- It's here, it's here!
- It's here!
- Get it!
- There!
- I think they got it, get it.
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here!